okay hi welcome
hi
thank you
you are alive
so
how many of you are writing
front-end applications using javascript
or typescript
okay and how many of you are using the
new fancy stuff uh webassembly binary
javascript
okay couple of you
so i i have to tell you enough to be
perfectly honest with you for all of my
life i was a server guy i don't care at
all about uis
okay
especially if they have to run in the
browser yeah
um but
we have many customers that that do care
okay
so uh you know and um i'm helping them
writing them in a secure way and
and uh you know
javascript browser-based applications
just in general are a security nightmare
they are
yeah it's not the fault of javascript
it's not the fault of whatever it's it's
just the
the the facts that they are running in a
very hostile environment yeah that is
called the internet and the world wide
web and so on so
i felt really bad for my customers right
because
even more than in the back end it seemed
like that the guidance how to protect
and write applications on the front end
has changed even more often right it it
went from you know like a pendulum going
this direction you have to do it like
this oh no that's all wrong now it's
swinging in this direction you have to
do it like this to fix your stuff before
oh that's wrong too now
so
the way i see it and that's kind of like
the
the idea or that the goal of the talk is
i think now that we've seen both
extremes i think that the truth as very
often is somewhere in the middle and
that's all that is and that is what this
pattern is about it's called bff the
back end for front-end pattern which is
all about
using the best of both worlds using the
ui technologies you have on the front
end and using the security features you
have on the back end and combine them
together to make something meaningful
yeah
so that's the whole idea of that talk
my name is dominic
and
i've been whoops
working for many many years in in that
space
helping customers building
authentication and authorization uh
systems and helping them secure their
applications and
uh one one central piece of that work
is uh
two protocols that i mostly care about
which is open id connect and oauth that
is how i spend the better half of my
career by implementing them in this
thing called identity server which is um
um
an asp.net core add-on if you like to
build uh
oauth and openly connect uh server
capabilities into into your software so
that's my background basically
um
and you know as part of that of course i
needed to help you know because at the
end of the day the back end guys have to
realize the only reason the back end
exists is because there are front ends
to connect to it right so that's kind of
like the way it works so
um
i basically want to explore a little bit
of the history how people were writing
browser-based applications in the past
yeah and what is wrong with one approach
and what is wrong with the other
approach and i think where is the sweet
spot where we're going to end with okay
so i want to first have
um a look at what i call
the cookie era
but before i even start i should set the
scene a little bit yeah because um i
wrote a blog post a long time ago in
2020 it was called spars are dead
and this got picked up by hacker news
right and people on hacker news have a
very short attention span all they read
was the headline they didn't even bother
to read maybe the first line after that
which said yeah it's a joke right but
they were like going completely crazy on
me like this guy does nothing that knows
nothing about sparse they are not dead
blah blah blah blah blah
if they would have taken the time to
read
what i was talking about is i was
proposing
an alternative approach to secure spas
okay which was a blog post i wrote
earlier and which was like my very first
ideas around how to use the back end for
front-end pattern to to secure those
applications right um
but one thing they had a point with one
thing is you know that sparse are many
things to many people right and when i
mean sparse you know the world i'm
living in i'm not a game developer i'm
you know like i'm living in in this
boring business world right my customers
are writing business applications right
uh forms over data
you know corporate stuff you know things
like that yeah
um and in that
in that
um
world you know we
typically do stuff like we do
authentication via open id connect we do
a single sign-on we do federation with
external providers yeah software as a
service style
um applications and so on and we are
also calling apis okay so if you are
living in that world then that's what i
meant with the current way how we do
spas is wrong if you're not living in
that world then you might have different
approaches that i don't know about but
that's just not what i want to talk
about today or my focus is on how to to
secure business applications
okay
and you know business applications can
be a whole lot of things right i mean
the azure portal is a spa
yeah that needs security would you agree
um
the banks are sparse these days the
health you know the health care systems
are written in javascript right i mean
they need security and they all fall
under this category that i want to talk
about
so as i said the first thing i want to
talk about is like how you did
sparse and they weren't even called spas
by the time like back in the days okay
so many many customers we have you know
they started like
in the early 2000s with web forms or mvc
right
classical server side
web rendering style right where you
render the page and you
did a post back back to the server and
and then suddenly
this hx thing became fashionable right
um
for those who are old enough you maybe
remember when microsoft showed the hx
control toolkit like an add-on for
asp.net like look at that no flickering
no more browser postbacks it's also
responsive isn't that cool right and
they started shipping jquery with
asp.net for example right to enable
people to build these more interactive
experiences right but what these
applications basically were they were
classic server-side rendered apps spiced
up with ajax right to make it nicer yeah
and because the classic server side
um
security mechanism was cookies they also
used ajax
to do the cookie
sorry they also use cookies to do the hx
calls the nice thing is it just worked
there was no extra code necessary you
know it the browser didn't care if it
was a post back or if it was an ajax
call as long as you had a cookie that
would could flow to the back end it all
just worked right
all was good and happy until someone
discovered cross-site request forgery
yeah which is um you know you you'll see
that theme here that many attacks in the
browser have the word cross at the
beginning right because the way i like
to see a browser these days it's like a
little operating system right where
every tab is a process that you need to
protect from other tabs right um but
there were some shared resources like
cookies for example
and the whole idea in browser-based
attacks typically is how can one app
attack another app and that's where the
cross-site comes from where site
typically is the assumption it's coming
from a different site right and they
want to attack you so what's cross-site
request forgery
um
you know it is just the way how the
browsers worked
by the time is that you have a browser
you have a tab you go to that to your
application you log into the application
you get your authentication cookie and
all is good right now you're opening
another tab in the same browser and
you're going to an evil application
yeah that evil application starts making
calls to this to the back end of app
app.com and by virtue of having a cookie
from app.com the browser will happily
send that authentication cookie back to
app.com right so in other words in that
tab
now the evil application can make
back-end calls impersonating the
lockdown user in this tab
that's cross-site request forgery yeah
so let me show you that
example because
every now and then i have people in the
room saying this can't be true if that
would be true
the web would be broken
right and they are right
it is
okay but let's let's do this i have two
applications here my app and evil app
okay so let's run my app first
just to illustrate the problem and the
solution as well
okay so here's my app imagine this is a
an app i'm logging in right imagine that
this is now something that makes an ajax
call to the back end that that is that
that is doing some work under the
currently logged on user doing work as
alice good okay so now
let's run evil app
i mean who could resist
right
of course i will click this
but before we click it let's just have a
look what it does
so let's go to the page source
and you see that i don't even need to do
any javascript here all this is doing is
basically doing a cross site post to the
other application
okay
so what do you expect to see when i
click this
i'm doing work as alice
right
because
i did a post the browser sent the cookie
along i'm authenticated in the other pa
in the other tab so to speak
yeah that is cross site request buttery
okay and of course you know um
i don't i can make this much smarter
right i don't need a user to click on
something i can have a javascript thing
saying submit the form automatically
right i can make this in a hidden iframe
so they won't even see the kittens never
yeah
so but yeah that is um that is
cross-eyed request forgery right and if
you um we're building apis and servers
and endpoints using cookies as the
security mechanism you were vulnerable
to this attack unless you protected
yourself against this
okay
so what is
the protection mechanism
well it is
adequately called
anti-forgery
okay
so the whole idea is this yeah and and
probably probably everyone knows this or
should notice because this was part of
mvc right from the start right there was
this attribute
on your controller's validate and
defaultery token right and what this
basically did is when you were rendering
down a form it was basically issuing a
cookie the so-called anti-forgery cookie
um and it was basically that had a value
and they put the same value in a hidden
form field called the request
verification token so now when you post
that form back right uh both the cookie
and the hidden field post back to the
server this attribute kicks in and make
sure that both values are the same
right so now if you imagine now my
attack scenario i just showed you if i'm
doing this cross side form post i don't
know the value of this okay so it's
missing
and then the server will reject
the post yeah so we can we can do that
it's easy
um
let's go here
and on my on my app
uh sorry on my app
oops
on my app here is my do work
right
i would do a validate
and defaultry token
okay so run this again my app
okay i'm logged in as alice
run the evil app again
click here to see kittens
doesn't work anymore
right because that request verification
token is missing the the
the filter said no you're not allowed in
you get basically an exception on the
server
okay
so why why is this important well
while this attribute
was part of every single
mvc template you can imagine that
microsoft put out it was not part of any
of the web api related templates
right so many people didn't know about
this attack um because it was not on in
the template right also for web apis you
need to write over for hx calls you need
to write some extra code right because
you you don't just do a form post and
this thing flows you would have to write
some javascript code to fetch the token
from the form put it on a header then
send the header along with the cookie
and then have some code comparing the
header value with the cookie value and
that all of that was never part of mvc
that's why believe me i have done many
code reviews in my life where people
knew about this for a ui but did not
even know that this was an issue for
apis
right and they were using cookies
and they were vulnerable to across that
request forgery
okay that's just the way it is
um
and again you met this is like 15 years
ago right we're basically trying to work
our way up to today
um
so what happened next yeah
the ietf which is this
standard body right the internet
engineering task force they became aware
of this problem and they were working on
this thing called oauth and they felt
like huh
what if we could extend o of in a way
that you could
get rid of your cookies all together in
the browser and use access tokens
instead
right access tokens don't have this
issue because they're not sent
automatically so we could solve this
problem right um
but
to get access tokens basically by the
time you had to do like cross
cross side calls to the token server to
ask for a token get a token back and so
on and this wasn't easily possible
because
cross-origin resource sharing didn't
exist by the time right there was no
easy way to make cross-site ajax calls
by the time yeah that the same origin
policy prohibited that yeah so they came
up with uh a simplified version of doing
that which is called the implicit flow
okay
um they knew they're making a lot of
security compromises there
but they wanted to make it work for
browser-based applications the implicit
folder worked like this basically here's
your javascript it makes a get request
to the token server and it gets back
again
a get request back and the access token
was on the url
right and then you would store that url
that that token and would start calling
apis no cookies involved
yeah
so that looked good this actually made
it into a real standard in oauth 2.0
yeah yeah
until they realize that there's a
different problem here it's called uh
cross-site scripting right um
so the first problem we had is is that
token transmission over over urls is
extremely leaky right urls end up in log
files in the browser history in headers
in reverse proxies wherever you can
imagine these headers are getting stored
because typically the assumption is
there is no sensitive data
on a url
right it shouldn't be
um
so this became a security nightmare
actually because now these tokens were
spread all over the place right
and you had to write some complicated
javascript code for example to delete
the browser history after you got the
token and
whatever right
so that was the first big problem here
that the transmission
wire this redirect mechanism was not
very secure
um
so they basically said okay we should
use a different flow now yeah don't use
implicit flow anymore if you have
written your application using bluetooth
flow you're doing it wrong now yeah
it was okay yesterday but today it's
wrong
yeah so dave basically said okay there's
another flow in oauth that is better
basically you start a front channel
approach you know like you you go to the
token server um and
collect some artifacts but the actual
token is not coming back on the browser
you're now making an hx call to the back
end and retrieve the token
outside of the url so to speak you have
to solve the url problem okay and then
in the end you have to store and manage
that token
next problem
is is storage mechanisms in browsers
secure
well the answer is no
i mean secure is the wrong word maybe
yeah if the browser has several ways to
store data right it could be in memory
it could be in session storage could be
in local storage could be in web
indexeddb all kinds of things right but
all of these mechanisms are by design
accessible by javascript
right and now with the upcoming thread
of cross-site scripting yeah what
cross-site scripting really means is is
that somebody else can execute
javascript code in your application
right you're getting some string you're
not properly sanitizing that you're
outputting it it happens to be
javascript bang the attacker runs code
in your process
yeah
um up till today this is not a solved
problem if you look at the over top 10
for the last 10 years it was always
between
number one and number three it's kind of
like going up and down but it's not a
solved problem yeah um cross-site
cross-site scripting is a real
uh a real problem that still happens
today
um and in other words if now somebody
can execute javascript code in your
application they can reach to whatever
storage mechanism you're using and
exfiltrate those tokens and send them
away okay this is not not an exotic
uh i don't know dystopian
thing it's it's happening actually
okay
um
oh yeah and there's more really scary
stuff going on you remember the spectre
attacks
you know like um we're basically
exploiting
exploiting um intel cpus that when you
send some weird stuff you could you're
now starting to read memory
right that was a main thing for servers
but google found out with with valid
javascript you can provoke specter
attacks in the memory of the browser
okay
so i don't think a browser is a good
place to store sensitive data
it's just the way it is okay
so
the or folks
kind of said like yeah it's not perfect
from a security point of view you should
reduce the exposure of these tokens
there's this thing called refresh tokens
for example in oauth that gives you
long-lived access to an api they are
forbidden in implicit flow because it
was just too dangerous right i mean
getting an access token is bad getting a
refresh token gives you a way to get new
access tokens yeah and since um
javascript applications are public
clients by design there's no client
secret if i steal your refresh token i
can happily get new access tokens as
long as i want probably yeah so they
didn't allow that and came up with other
mechanisms or workarounds to um
to do this right um
[Music]
let me show you
just so that we are all on the same page
here let me show you
uh an example of a of an app
that does everything
from within javascript
right there there's no back end involved
here it's basically as you can see all
i'm doing here on the back end is really
just serving static files everything
else is happening in javascript yeah
so when i run this
um
app
you see now you know that's how far my
ui skills go um
i can basically log in i can call apis
and so on right so let's try this let's
log in
okay i'm logging in
and yeah um mission mission accomplished
right i now have an access token
in the browser so i can call my apis
right
um so i think i can even call the api
yeah it works okay
but if i now look
um
if i now look at
my session storage in the browser of
course this must be stored somewhere
right and here it is and of course if i
can now inject javascript into this
application i can exfiltrate the token
and steal them
yeah
okay
next challenge
token and session management so let's
say we're going down the javascript
route there are no refresh tokens so we
can't re you know we can't get new
access or we should not do that right um
so they came up with a different
technique called silent renew and the
idea was that you're opening an
invisible iframe that does another token
request under the covers and the cookie
is flowing to the server and while while
the user is still locked in you will get
new access tokens without having to have
a refresh token and when the user signs
out it won't work anymore which was kind
of like not a bad idea yeah
so that
utilized an iframe
the next challenge you have when you're
writing a read application is
session change notifications right so
when the user logs out from the server
maybe your javascript application wants
to know that there's a log out going on
to clean up data and and block him out
right so how do you do that well
again another iframe technique was
invented that basically i'll show you in
a second how that works here
long story short they found some
workarounds to make this a little bit
better
using iframes
so let me show you that
um let's just do this again
log in here
you see now um
there is
a renew token
okay so when i when i click the renew
token button
don't click it
yeah you see that i'm getting new tokens
no flickering in the browser mission
accomplished
right
so that is and i'll show you how it
works um
that is uh let's do inspect
you see here um here's my application so
when i renew the token you will see for
us for a split second or so a new iframe
coming going up that this does just do
the token request and give me back a new
token see that
okay
that is the replacement for refresh
tokens in the browser so a workaround to
make that
security story a little bit better
here is the other thing i talked about
that is an iframe that points to an
endpoint on the identity server right
and it's called check session and
basically how that works is you open the
iframe and just leave it there and then
a server-side event is coming from the
server back to your client telling you
the user is locked out you should now
clean up your stuff
okay
so i can show you that too so if i go to
the actual token server
you see here i'm logged in
so when i click the log out button here
magic happens
okay and that basically is a server side
event coming from the token server down
to my javascript client and that are
basically the two things you need to
write a real application you need token
lifetime management and you need session
lifetime management
okay
cool so that was kind of working
and to be honest we wrote a client
library like seven years ago that is
pretty popular it's called oidc
client.js
and we decided to
archive
the repo
one and a half years ago
because it was just
i shouldn't swear here so i won't
it was very bad
and that was not the library what was
really bad is is that the javascript
landscape and the browser landscape is
changing so rapidly yeah having to
maintain a library that is supposed to
work in all browsers is just a nightmare
right
that combined with you know new
techniques in javascript webpack and all
of that stuff i mean you know did you
know that even
opening a pop-up window in a browser is
not standardized chrome does it
differently than firefox firefox does it
differently than
uh what else safari i guess yeah
but people want to have login pages as
pop-up windows yeah
whatever yeah so we decided now we are
we are too old for that
um if somebody wants to take it over
they can there there are actually some
guys who take took it over they now have
a typescript version of that which was
another thing that people asked for you
know i don't care about typescript
anyways so
this library this this spa app i just
showed you is using our library which
automated all of these things
um
now
going back to last year
uh is it last year i think
it is last 2021
late 2020
um the browser vendors decided they now
need to fight back on tracking
mechanisms in browsers right like uh ads
networks and and this
all that stuff that people use to track
you across websites to give you better
better ads basically yeah and they i
identified that one of the techniques
that people are using to do this secret
tracking
across sites guess what is iframes with
cookies
so now they are deciding we're going to
turn this off we don't we won't allow
any more iframes going to to cross side
in sorry we won't allow cookies anymore
going cross-side in iframes do you see a
problem here i just showed you some two
brand new specifications from the o of
working group that solved the problem
with iframes and cookies
well not anymore
so
today
there is one company that did that so
far which is apple
right and safari has a reasonable market
share right so if it only would be
firefox or something people would say
like yeah that's a hippie browser right
who
who uses that but it's safari right it's
safari on mac os and on ios which has a
15 market share
that is enough to ask yourself huh
do i have customers that use safari you
probably have
right
um
of course other browsers like brave and
firefox they do the same thing now but
no one cares about them but guess who's
coming next year
chrome
okay and with chrome
they turn this off i can tell you it's
going to be the same
disaster as two years ago when they
turned on same side cookies
right where they actually had to realize
oh beginning of 2020 we just broke half
of the internet maybe that was bad
timing
yeah because all of the websites stopped
working including things like you know
healthcare systems red cross first
responders
so they had to they had to remove that
feature again
and then it came back again end of 2020.
yeah so
let me show you that
um actually let's
let's take the app i just ran
which is not running anymore
[Music]
and just run the same
spa in safari
great it looks almost the same
um
now
just to show you what's happening now is
this i'm doing login right
i'm going to the server i log in
and then i will get back my tokens and
so on
and then the client will open this
iframe to wait for session change
notifications right
now this iframe does not contain my
session cookie anymore so the server
will immediately say you are anonymous
you're not even locked in
okay and that's exactly what we're
seeing now when i log in here
so i'm logging in
all is good so far
i'm coming back
out
okay
because the iframe does not contain the
session anymore
which is the cookie
um and of course the the renew thing
doesn't work either of course because
that is using the same technique
so yeah this is not working anymore
yeah this this even has a name now it's
called the google chrome cookie
pocalypse
and it's it's it's right now it's
planned to happen in 2023 there is
actually the eu trying to prohibit that
yeah because they know that all of the
government stuff isn't working anymore
so yeah not a good situation to be in
um yeah so that's what i just said yeah
these things don't work anymore
now
for something good now there are also
good browser changes okay so and you
know um one of the the good browser
changes is that all major browsers
are basically trying to solve now the
cross-site request forgery problem
okay so remember remember what was the
problem of crosshat request forgery
basically the browser got a cookie from
server one
um and then somebody else who who was
not server one posted back to server one
and the browser was sending the cookie
along because it belonged to server one
right that that's the
the essence of it yeah now guess what
they have this thing called same side
cookies and what that expresses is is
that if you have a cookie for server one
you should only post it back if the
postback comes from a page originating
from server one right and if the page is
coming from server two you don't post
that cookie back and now you have to
wonder why wasn't it like that all from
the start
wouldn't that you know that would have
saved us a lot of pain ma'am so yeah
same side cookies as i said this caused
a massive problem when chrome turned
them on beginning of 2020 but now
they all turned it on
and
arguably it makes the internet a safer
place it was just breaking everyone and
they all had to learn that in really
hard lessons yeah
um
what does that mean
that means that now suddenly in 2022
there is
maybe you should give cookies a second
look right because they are much better
as they used to be 15 years ago
okay
and
just to you know as a side note
same side cookies but basically means um
that cookies can flow freely within the
same site now some people are confused
what's the site and what's an origin and
origin is very strict right an origin
basically
is the combination of protocol server
name port that's an origin right and the
browser prevents cross-origin requests
now what's the site the site is much
broader basically if you have a
top-level domain like myapp.com then all
of the sub-domains are on the same site
meaning if you have app one myapp.com it
can post cookies to app too myapp.com
okay that is kind of like the boundary
here um which of of course makes total
sense if you trust all your sub domains
right
and in big companies right
many teams own different sub domains do
you know that every team is writing
secure code
or is there something that could happen
if you know
crm.mycompany.com posts to my
secureapi.mycompany.com right
um so yeah just be aware of that same
site is not like the the silver bullet
but it
by default built into the browser
without you having to do anything it
will shield you from attacks from other
sites
which is not bad to start with at least
good
so
now with all of that said now we are
here today there is now new
recommendation from the ietf they
removed implicit flow from oauth because
they realized it's a bad idea it's gone
it's deprecated you shouldn't use it
they even removed it completely from the
rfc
because they are now doing a revision of
oauth yeah
so now what do we do
do we
do cookies again do we stay with tokens
what's the best way to do it right and
how often have we already rewritten our
application so far
yeah
so
um
there is some good good documents coming
out of that
especially the one here it's called
oauth for browser-based applications
best current practices which is not a
spec it's more like a guidance document
and the way they phrase it and that is
basically what i totally agree with
there are two types of javascript
applications
the ones with the back end and the ones
without a back end
so
the ones without a back end you know
like this this this stream from the all
of these javascript hipsters right all
we need is a cdn that deploys our html
css and javascript that's all we need
because from that point on it's a
standalone application running in the
browser yeah
don't think so um
if you're staying with this architecture
then you're pretty pretty much in in the
boat of doing everything from javascript
and just what i showed you right with
storing stuff in the browser fighting
with browser changes and all of that
so that the spec says very clearly if
you are not dealing with sensitive data
stay on this architecture
but if you're dealing with sensitive
data and that's what most of my
customers are doing actually probably
all then you should
consider this approach here where you
are using the browser and your favorite
browser framework angular react
whatsoever to show the nice uis
right but all of the security all of the
token management all of the interaction
with your
authentication system and so on and so
forth it should be on the server
okay
yes and that is as i said the one thing
that i totally agree with
now
um there's a second spec now there um
that
you know this is such a young pattern
but still starts people start to now
make variations of it already
um and that there's one pattern called
so if if you come across that they call
it tmi bff uh something with it it's
supposed to be like a funny wordplay
something with mediate uh something
something but it's also too much
information
and the idea is that you're basically
moving
parts of your security stuff on the
server and parts stay
on the browser i don't agree with that
and i have i argued with them until they
added this wording here uh into the spec
which is called
a full bff where everything is
happening on the server offers better
security
right that was just getting this
sentence in was an interesting
experience
um
okay let me quickly show you the tmi
approach and then forget it again i mean
no but just you know
that you've seen it before so so the
idea with the tmi approach is basically
here's your front end
then if you need a token you go to the
back end the back end does all the
interaction with the token server right
and then stores the token response on
the back end but then when the front end
wants to call the api it can get the
token to the front end and call the api
which in my opinion is not really the
solution because you're still ending up
with tokens in the browser
yeah they might have a shorter lifetime
and all of the refresh handling is done
on the server but ultimately
you end up with access tokens in the
browser that's why i don't like this
approach yeah again my
preferred approach is what they call the
full bff now where basically everything
is happening on the application server
and whenever the browser wants to do
something it calls the application
server and the application server calls
whatever they need to do okay and the
browser is purely for a ui
okay
so that is a bff it's called back-end
for front-end and the idea is as i just
said you get the best of both worlds you
get the responsiveness the javascript
stuff the the ui stuff in the browser
but the security stuff is on the server
and i think that is a good compromise
okay
so let's let's let's do this um
so um
i i should mention um i've been working
on a product for that um that that
puts these things all together um it's
free
um if you are if you you or your company
is making less than one million usd a
year which is a pretty fair deal i think
otherwise if you're making more than one
million i guess you can afford it um
but the idea is this most of the sixty
percent of the plumbing you need to
build the bff is already in asp.net core
okay and what is this it basically is
your open id connect an oauth client
library it is part of asp.net core this
is the thing that goes to the open id
connect server that sends the right
parameters that handles the response
back from the server that gets the
tokens and so on
session management is part of asp.net
core it's it's it's basically the cookie
handler right the thing that sets a
cookie that keeps the session alive that
maybe does ex sliding exploration or
absolute exploration basically the thing
that lets your front end call the back
end
under your control
the thing that is not part of asp.net is
token management so basically once you
have the need of calling apis that are
cross-site you need an access token
access tokens means you need refresh
tokens someone must need to manage them
right get a new refresh token when the
other expired
that is an open source library i wrote
which is available on the internet
and then the last interesting
point is now your front-end wants to
call apis right um and there are two
types of apis in my mind so when you
know when you start refactoring your
application to use this pattern you
realize there's a whole bunch of apis
i'm calling which are exclusive for my
front and no one else calls them right
so what's the point of putting them onto
a shared server i can just put them in
the back end and i i don't even have to
go cross-site for that
right um and there is probably and
there's also the
the case of remote apis where an api is
shared between multiple front-ends so it
must be on a shared server and in that
case then the back end will help you to
proxy those requests over and send the
response back to the to the front end
and the very last thing is the ui
okay so choose whatever ui you like you
know could be razer could be mvc could
be react
could be angular could be blazer doesn't
matter right it's just something in the
browser that shows
colored pictures yeah
good
so yeah i just mentioned that
um
so what are the building blocks if you
want to build a bff back end yourself
um first of all you would need eight
minute course help static files right to
serve your static assets down to the
browser html javascript css all these
things
you would need the asp.net core open the
connect authentication handler to do the
coordination to the authentication
system and token system and you would
need the cookie handler to do all of the
same side cookies and default
reprotection and so on
okay
so that's
all there if you've done this before you
know what what i'm showing here that's
the openid connect handler you just
connect it to your
to your company authentication system
okay
once the authentication is done with
that system you need to start managing
the session as i said the session
is a part of asp.net all you basically
need to give the front end
is a way to trigger the login process
right and that's how you do that
basically by
providing
um an end point in your back end
and if javascript or whatever goes to
that end point you trigger the login
server side
and you you do the same for the logout
okay and after the login you then just
use the standard cookie handling asp.net
core to set the cookie you see they have
support for same side cookies and all of
that so you can make this really secure
let me show you then
so we're here
so you see this is basically just a just
a normal
asp.net core
web web application okay
the only difference is that we don't
have server side ui the ui is all
javascript yeah
so um
and you see all the configuration going
on here here's my open id connect
plumbing here's my
cookie plumbing with the same side
settings and so on so when i
when i run this
it's the front end host
you see that is everyone needs a to-do
list right
so
um now if if i want to start the
application and log in the user you can
see when i hover over here all this
login button really does is it does it
does a redirect to a local endpoint
called login
okay and then this local endpoint on the
server side will trigger
the login to the authentication system
just like before
okay
um login
and now i'm logged in
um what do i have in my in my browser
now
nonsense
um
no cookies in session store right all i
sorry no no data in session store but i
have this bff cookie right and you can
see it has it is secure it's http only
meaning no javascript that has access to
it and the same side mode is strict
which is the highest
mode you can get for cross-site request
forgery protection
right so in other words what this is now
doing is it it just allows you to call
back to your back end and nothing else
okay you're basically sandboxing the
front end to be only able to call the
back end
right
um
so if i want to log out again you see
same same thing i just invoke a local
logout endpoint so if i do that
i'm back here
and i'm locked out let's look log back
in
and if the front end needs to know
who the user is right for
personalization
reasons like here like logged in as bob
smith things like that right there is a
local endpoint on the server that
basically
returns whatever session information you
want to return back to the client and
you see my ui skills are really not
so good um but you see basically it
gives you back things like what's the
name of the user you know and you can
put in arbitrary stuff here but it's
only accessible it's protected by the
same side cookie and only the front end
can retrieve that information and no one
else
cool so that's working it's great
um
[Music]
let's go back
what else do we need
yeah we've just seen that oh by the way
there's a great trick you know like one
of the challenges we have
was uh session change notifications
right so how does the front end know if
the user has signed out on the server
maybe in a different application yeah
and since this iframe trick is not
working anymore you can you know you can
come up with something really fancy like
some sort of signalr thing right that
gives you a notification from the server
back down
um very nice starting with dot net 6.0
there is a way now that you can make
requests to the server
without
triggering
[Music]
sliding exploration cookies so let's say
for example you want to have like a uh
every minute you want to go to the
server so like is the user still logged
in is user still logged in right if you
would do that then you would if the
cookie is sliding you would
prolong the session every time you're
doing that right starting with dotnet 8.
core 6 there's now a way how you can
suppress this
so you really can check is the user
still logged in without touching the
server side session which is quite nice
um
right
now
now who does um how what what's the
modern solution for
fashion lockout notifications to the
back end well
there was a spec that is around for
quite a while but nobody implemented it
um because people were relying on
another iframe based approach that
doesn't work anymore which was called
front channel notifications there's now
a um another stack which is called back
channel notifications that if you have a
good token server they can just
basically not notify the back end hey
the user session has ended which means
the back end ends the session of the
user the next time you ask for the
session it will say it's gone that's how
you can trickle down um session change
notifications from the token system down
to
the
ui
now asp.net core does not implement this
right now because they would you know
they didn't see a need but you know what
microsoft's
big authentication product called azure
ad is always by design cross site to
your applications right because your
application runs on mycompany.com and
azure red runs on
login.microsoft.com right all of the
things i just mentioned to you
cross-site iframes notifications will
not work anymore when google pulls the
trigger
so you can be sure that pretty soon this
will be part of asp.net core
built in or you just use our
implementation
good
um let's talk about the last thing
calling apis and and i already did that
right so my my to-do list thing over
actually i didn't i think yeah i did not
call an api yet
right so here is uh you know
uh have a beer soon
okay
that is calling a local to-do list
controller right so i can now add my
to-do's and delete them and so on um but
this to-do controller as you can see
is local
to my application okay so i'm not even
crossing a side boundary which means i
don't even need oauth access tokens
because i'm just doing a call to the
same side which is protected by the
cookie which is all good okay
and you can even make that even stronger
by by a nice little trick let me show
you that um
it it sounds silly and i didn't believe
it to start with but basically when
you're doing the the back end call to
your local api endpoint yeah you are all
automatically protected by same side
cookies okay that is what we get from
from the browser for free
but what if you even want to protect
yourself against other sub domains in
your on your top level domain
right
um
and the reasons might be manifold yeah
um you can just add a header and you can
call this header whatever you want and
you can set the value to whatever you
want yeah but basically what that means
is by virtue of doing an ajax call from
the browser
that contains a cookie and a custom
header the browser will always trigger
course preflight requests
okay the course is the thing that would
allow you to do cross-site api calls
right we don't want that we don't want
cross-site api because we want to
prohibit them
okay so so when you're doing a
cross-site api call the browser uses
this thing called course cross-origin
resource sharing there are two modes in
course um one mode is for get requests
where they basically just do the get
request and then expect a certain header
to come back from the server and only if
the headers match they pass the response
down to javascript that is the
the easiest one but for more complicated
calls and that's exactly that thing
makes it more complicated from a browser
point of view
they first asked the server are you okay
with me making this call and only if you
say yes i will actually do the call
why is this better
now remember specter attacks
right specter attacks means you probably
can read the ram of the browser process
so it would be better if the data
wouldn't even ever come to the browser
in the first place
right so that is
you know it's beauty
so
yeah so just by adding this static
header here you have protected yourself
against even same side attacks
right where uh subdomain one in your
company has some
dodgy code running that attacks
subdomain two on the same company
yeah or maybe your sub domain was stolen
right have you ever heard of sub sub
domain takeover attacks
that's how attackers can basically steal
a subdomain from you because you have a
dangling dns pointer pointing to azure
and they just have to register the azure
website with the same name and suddenly
they run code on your domain
these things exist
i told you the web is not a peaceful
place
okay so that's how you call local apis
no need for access tokens it's just
protected by cookie and
anti-forge reprotection so what if you
want to call external apis or remote
apis well you know essentially what you
need to do is you need to do reverse
proxying
okay that doesn't sound sexy but it
works
yeah
and how you do the reverse boxing
totally up to you there are many many
ways of doing that
i like this new thing here have you
heard of yap
which is a really stupid name
it's called yet another reverse proxy
but it's easy to google believe me yap
will be the first hit when you google
for yap right because i guess the app is
just you know whatever anyways it's a
microsoft product and the idea is that
the reverse proxy is just a middleware
in your host meaning you have an in-app
reverse proxy that you can configure in
a way saying like hey when a request
comes in on slash api forward that to
another server get the response back and
send the response back to the
front end and the front end doesn't
doesn't does never know even that this
was a remote call it all looks like a
local api endpoint it's great right
yeah so that's exactly what we did as
well so you see
let's say
let's say we
remove the to-do controller from our
front end here
and i go to my program cs you see here
sorry startup it's now called or it was
called um you see here at the end
um i just
removed the local api endpoint
altogether
and then i replace that with what we
call a remote
api endpoint and that is utilizing yap
under the cover so yap is not like a
server thing it's it's it's an api
right that you can use yourself and what
this basically says is whenever a call
comes in on slash to do's on the local
host forward that call to this server
here oh and by the way because now we
are on a cross-site scenario please
attach the current access token of the
user so it all just works protected by
oauth
right
so if i run this again now sorry run the
back end first which now has the to-do
controller yeah and run the front end
run the front end again
okay
and as you can see i can still use my to
do api the front end is unchanged it
doesn't know anything about this but our
api has moved to a completely different
server
and is now protected by oauth so that
other clients can call it as well using
oauth maybe server to server maybe from
another application maybe maybe maybe
from a mobile app whatever right
but
the first hop front end to bff is
protected very strongly with same side
cookies and anti-forgery and then on the
server side we make a transition to a
server to server call attach the access
token get back to result and show that
back to the ui
okay
um
yeah that was it
so yeah that that was the thing i was
working on for the last year basically
triggered by various
customer problems and once we solved it
the first time i started to see the
pattern here and that's where we turned
it into a framework
but that's that's my conclusion okay so
i've i'm i'm old enough and i have
enough gray hair to to remember the
cookie era and the token era and they
both were
problematic okay
and this here i think the first time i
think this makes sense yeah do a clean
separation of concerns
do your ui in the browser do your
security on the server
any questions
yep
you mean like if somebody steals the
cookie
well that was always a concern right
that would mean that they have some some
sort of
um local access to your hard disk maybe
yeah this this this doesn't solve that
problem yeah
the yap actually does support
web sockets and grcp
yeah
any other questions
good then
almost on time thank you and have a
great conference